hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well ethics book 10
Aristotle finally delivers on a promise
that you made all the way in the
beginning of the work in nikka McKay
ethics book one then is to talk about
the contemplative or the theoretic a
life the life that involves theoria
which means looking upon contemplating
thinking about all these sorts of things
are sort of rolled up in it and it comes
originally from from a term that means
to look upon something as it going to a
spectacle but it comes to take on the
sentence very quickly intellectual life
the life that engages the Zehra so
what's at the highest part of ourselves
and so what we're interested in finding
out of here is well what is the life of
contemplation and what is its value so
Aristotle says that it is the best and
the happiest life it is the life of
happiness to a greater degree even more
than the life of happiness that he's
been discussing throughout the rest of
the Nicomachean ethics which is the life
of activity that that derives from
virtue the active exercise and
development of the virtues what we might
call the political or the social or the
active
life he's he's saying here that that's
really great and this is even that this
is the highest form of life possible in
the Nicomachean ethics he explicitly
identifies it with Phil Oh Sophia with
philosophy as the pursuit of wisdom that
is Sophia that the intellectual virtue
they we've done another video about that
you can check out so for humans and for
the gods this is the best and highest
form of activity in fact Aristotle
suggests that the gods don't even have a
choice about this they're not going to
be involved in the active life they're
just going to be involved in the life of
contemplation so why is this the best
life these are all the reasons that
Aristotle provides and considers the
first is that he says that it is the
highest form of activity the highest
form of energy of doing things that
human beings can do it why is it the
highest form of activity there's there's
two reasons one has to do with the
faculty that is engaged that is the part
of our soul the part of our personality
our makeup and that is the intellect our
cognitive side you could say is what is
doing all of the work not on our body
not our feelings not our drives except
perhaps for drive firt for truth or
drive for understanding so there's the
faculty and then there is the object of
that faculty what is it that the person
is contemplating they're not just
picking up a piece of chalk and staring
at it all day long that isn't a script
contemplation
nor is it mere a navel gazing as we say
you know self reflexive mind thinking
about itself although but ever so we'll
say in the metaphysics mind thinking
itself is at least as far as God goes is
that but he
beings aren't really capable of doing
that sort of contemplation
what are we constantly we're
contemplating the things that are you
know necessity the things that we can
add knowledge about the things that
remain the same or at least in their
changes follow certain fixed principles
the things that we can't occupy our
minds with so in certain ways the
scientific life although very different
than the science that we think of today
in many respects what else
Aristotle says that intellectual work of
this sort for the people that actually
have cultivated their intellects not for
everybody necessarily but those who
really are engaged in this who have
developed what we call intellectual
virtues this sort of activity provides
the greatest the purest that has least
mixed in with pains and the most lasting
pleasure Aristotle thinks that most of
the pleasures that we feel are not
sustainable for very long and if you
think about examples in a how long can
you taste particularly good food even by
the end of the dish it doesn't actually
taste the same you know as Henry Miller
once once said in one of his books I
don't remember which one why is it that
we work when all it's something we can
actually do for eight hours a day and
not become totally sick of where it is
trying to you know have sex for eight
hours a day or eat find food eight hours
a day maybe what are people to do it the
first day but you're not going to be
able to keep it up and so this is in
fact something that you can't keep up
816 hours a day once you've become you
know versed in how how to do it so we're
able to have the the greatest the
longest the most pure pleasure from
contemplation it's also as Aristotle
says a life of greater self sufficiency
than the active life of the
and here he has in mind you know what we
might call the social or political life
where you need some resources in order
to exercise certain of the virtues it's
hard to be generous if you don't have
any wealth to be generous with let alone
magnificent which is generosity larger
scales and it's difficult to be right
amount of ambition if you have zero
prospects whatsoever you know in order
to exhibit courage for Aristotle you
needed to actually be able to go out on
the battlefield and that required having
a suit of armor that everybody could
afford there's other ways of being
courageous of course but here's the long
and short of it the life of
contemplation doesn't really take that
much you don't have to have an awful lot
of money you don't have to have you know
great prospects you don't need to have a
powerful position you don't need to have
family connections as a matter of fact
this is even more true today given the
resources available with the internet
and the fact that in most you know urban
centers and even in many rural areas we
have access to libraries all over the
place so that you know if we want to
engage in a life of knowledge it doesn't
really require that much of us you know
this book cost me when I bought it years
and years ago about 20 dollars I have
gotten you know 20 years of use out of
this book this plants and such you know
poor condition in many respects but you
can tell that it's a well-loved book
because of all the notes and because of
the fact that I have dried here and and
underlined and written marginalia it
doesn't take it an awful lot to be a
scholar now you know you might say well
wait a second what if we want to collide
you know particles with each other and
find out about the mysteries of the
universe yeah okay now you need a budget
for that sort of thing but now you're
involved with something that's not just
the life of contemplation now you're
involved with an entire
industry involved with what we do with
the fruits of contemplation and that's
more like the political life than the
purely contemplative life that aerosol
was talking about although that's worth
keeping in mind what else aerosol
suggests that there's some theological
dimensions to this as well this life is
higher than a simply human life it's
harder to begin with in a purely animal
life animals have no share in
contemplation Aristotle argues for that
reason can't be happy in that way and
animals also Aristotle things don't
really have any share inversion either
in part because they don't have the
intellectual part that we do in our soul
or our minds but the purely human life
is transcended by contemplation we enter
into something that is Aristotle says if
not itself divine in the same way that
the gods are at least in some sense of
participation in the divine we're doing
something like what the gods themselves
do the Aristotle says those who counsel
that human being should stick with
merely human thoughts are wrong about
this he goes on further a little bit
later on and suggest that the person who
pursues intellectual activity and
develops their intellect who maintains
it keeps it in good condition is
actually beloved by the gods why because
that person has something in common with
the gods that other people don't the
guys you know presumably or something
like pure pure intellects they don't
have bodies of our sort to drag them
down into mundane earthly things and
then you don't even exhibit virtues of
the sort that we talked about as moral
virtues like courage what are the gods
have to be afraid of right justice it's
not like the gods are engaging in
contract
with each other he goes on and on
whereas you know the gods or the divine
or whatever it is there are souls
talking about here they can see some
sort of similarity between themselves
and the person who is using the best and
finest and in a certain sense not only a
most divine but but most human part of
ourselves so all of these are arguments
Aristotle provides for why the
contemplative life the theoretical life
the life of philosophy is indeed the
best life